اخرى للخبر العاجل الذي تبعناه على الشاشه
قبل قليل عن اذاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي ان كل
من وزير الامن الداخلي بنكفير ووزير
الماليه شركاء نتنياهو في الائتلاف الحاكم
يدعوان للانضمام الى مظاهرات اليمين في
القدس الليله وبهذا الخبر اعود لك من جديد
لكن سيد امير تعليقك على هذه الدعوه من
قبل بنكفير والسموترج والى اي مدى يؤشر
ذلك الى الرغبه في الاستمرار في التحدي من
قبل هذه الحكومه من قبل نتنياهو
يعني فقط فقط ملاحظه بالنسبه للسؤال عن
الموقف الامريكي الموقف الامريكي ليس
مشغولا فقط بالديمقراطيه مع كل الاحترام
موقف الامريكي يرى في اسرائيل اهم استثمار
له واهم استثمار الاستراتيجي وبدا يتضرر
نتيجه حكومه بشكل جوهري بالنسبه للحقامات
الصهيونيه الدينيه هم اعضاء في مجموعه
ضمهم كانوا في التنظيم الارهابي اليهودي
الذي كان في سنوات الثمانين خاصه
الاستاذ وايضا هم يعني معنيين ليس
بالقانون الاسرائيلي ولا بالمنظومه
عقيدتهم هي تدمير البنيه الاسرائيليه
المنظومه الاسرائيليه القائمه من اجل
اقامه دوله شريعه تلائم اهواء في موضوع
دوله اسرائيل ارض اسرائيل الكبرى وراينا
الخارطه قبل ايام معطرش وموضوع الضم
وموضوع
عدم وجود شعب فلسطيني او بعدم وجود اي
الفلسطينيين الموجودين في ارض اسرائيل حسب
تعريفاتهم هذه المجموعه خطيره جدا ولديها
جمهور ليس بالكبير جدا لكن منظم جدا وعنيف
جدا وارهاب جدا يعني
حتى اغتيالات واطلاق نار واغتيارات سياسيه
ولديهم بالليشيات التي رايناها في حوار
وغيرها ونراها في في مسافه يطو وفي يعني
في كل انحاء الضفه في الهجوم اليومي اعتقد
ان هذه الدعوه هي اخر ما يملكه ليس اليمين
الفاسي وانما ياخذ ما يملكه نتنياهو هذه
بتحريض كانت جزء من التحريض لخروج اليمين
اليوم اتى من الكود من وزير القضاء لفين
وبتاييد من نتنياهو الذي ينتظره فعلا لكن
اعتقد ان هذه ستنقلب ايضا على نتنياهو
لانه هذه الحكومه بدات تارجح بشكل مخيف
سنشاركه بين كبير في هذه التظاهره طبيعي
انها تكون يعني
طبيعيه في الواقع لا طبيعي في اسرائيل
وهذه يعني ستؤدي الى اضعاف نتنياهو في
نهايه المطاف لانه سيكون سيبدو امام جمهور
امام حزبي انه يخضع الى الصهيونيه الدينيه
لم تنتهي الازمه
ولا توجد
مخارجت ازمه اليهود ازمه الدوله متكامله
وليست فقط ازمه